هناك سباق تسلح غربي المحيط الهادئ نراقب
الوضع عن كثب الصين تخطط للهيمنه على غرب
المحيط الهادئ خلال عشرين الى خمسه عشره
سنه تصريح يشري بحجم التنافس في المياه
الهادئه هنا وبالنظر الى غرب المحيط
الهادئ فالمنطقه المقصوده تطول لتشمل بحري
الصين الشرقي والجنوبي وتتجاوز تايوان
بؤره الصراع مع واشنطن وصولا الى جزر
سليمان في اقصى الجنوب الى الشرق من
استراليا الجزر التي جمعتها بالصين العمل
الفائت اتفاقيه امنيه اثارت حفيظه
الجيراني وغيرهم ومن خلال ما تعلنه واشنطن
وان لم تنفي او تؤكد لكنها تصرح بقدر ما
هو يستوجب الرد منها وكان تعدى الامر بها
غربي الهادئ الى اقصى شرقه حيث الهندوراس
بلد قطع علاقته مع تايوان واعلنها صراحه
نلتزم بصين واحده الصين وان لم تفصح
الولايات الم تحده عن طبيعه السباق في
التسلح تضرب عرض الحائط بردود فعل واشنطن
وما تصفها بالادعاءات الامريكيه ادعاءات
كان اخرها ان بكين اجبرت هندوراس على قطع
علاقتها بتايوان علقت عليها المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه ماونينج بمثل صيني خلاصه
يمر القارب بالاف الجبال وصراخ القرده
مستمر بلا نهايه